- This video describes EQ-RADIO,
a new technology from Professor
Katabi's group at MIT, that
can recognize people's emotions
using wireless signals.
Was there a moment in your life
when you looked at someone's
face, but you could not
figure out how they feel?
What if your wireless router
can tell people's emotions,
even if they don't show
them on their faces?
This is exactly what
our technology does.
This is our device.
The device transmits
a wireless signal
which reflects off a person's
body, and comes back.
It captures these
reflections, and analyzes them
to infer the person's emotions.
Specifically, our
algorithms zoom in
on the wireless
reflections to extract
the minute variations due
to breathing, and heartbeat.
We then further analyze
these reflections
to extract the breathing signal,
and the heart beat signal.
We then zoom in more
on these signals
to obtain individual heartbeat,
and breathing cycles,
and feed these as features into
a machine learning algorithm
to recognize that
person's emotions.
The device can
automatically know
if the person is excited,
angry, sad, or happy.
Our device can
recognize emotions
with an accuracy of 87%, while
relying purely on wireless
signals.
We envision that EQ-Radio can
be used in many applications.
It can recognize the
person's emotions
while he is watching a movie,
and provide movie makers
with better tools to
evaluate user experience.
It can also allow
smart environments
to detect emotional
states like depression,
and inform us to improve
our emotional well-being.
It can even enable
these environments
to react to our moods, and
adjust lighting or music
accordingly.
To learn more about
this research, please
check out our website.